hey girls just want to have fun death in
heaven I don't know how long this one's
gonna end up because there's very very
little I can talk about remember how
tied my hands were we're talking about
the last episode because it was all
spoilers well doubly so this time around
it was good it was solid there was some
moments especially towards the end they
really had a good solid emotional impact
on me so I feel this episode played its
cards pretty well and I'm on board and
rolling with what the sort of the reveal
did the deal with Missy is I'm on board
with that and I think you played out
well and it played out consistently
enough that after so we found out what
was going on last episode this episode
we get it full force and I feel it does
fit and it makes sense
we get some nice features for some nice
returning characters which I always
enjoy and I feel that they were well
utilized Danny pink and Clara once again
working very well individually even
better as a pair once Danny pink got
introduced Clara really became a
character that I enjoyed and that all
really sort of plays off very well in
this episode I've got a couple of
nitpicky logistical things that are
bugging me a little bit but that battle
be a spoiler discussion about the only
thing that that is more sort of
generalized as I said I wish was a
little bit different was you may
remember the last time I said the doctor
felt slightly sidelined and whether or
not that was going to be an issue was
going to depend on how central he was in
this episode well he's pretty central
but a lot of the emotional weight of the
episode is being carried by Clara and
Danny and I do feel that given what's
going on the doctor could have carried
that emotional weight himself I mean if
he's dealing with a lot on an emotional
level certainly but the show doesn't
allow him to be the standard-bearer for
the emotional impact that gets handed
off to Clara and Danny and again it's
done very well but just for my personal
preference of who I'd like more I kind
of wish the doctor was carrying more of
the weight of the episode on his
shoulders than he is that honestly
though that's a personal preference
goodness I think that's really about all
that I can say on this spoiler-free
review it was good it was a nice way to
wrap up I'm not gonna call it the
best series finale that we've had but
it's good it's solid it sort of calls
back to a number of things that happened
over this series and also even some
earlier ones and what it chooses to tie
up ties up well ties up nicely and I
like where it sort of points things
going in terms of where things might be
headed in the future and I really like
the Stinger at the end that sets up the
Christmas special those have kind of
become a little bit of a standard we get
those not every time but fairly
frequently we get a nice little button
that sets up the Christmas special we
got a bit more with Tennant with the
Titanic crashing in and Donna Noble
turning up and and all of that so we get
one of those at the end of these and end
it it made me smile it's goofy as heck
but it really and put a smile on my face
so I think that's about it for this one
I got to wrap it up because I really
want to talk spoilers and I got to do
that as a separate video so I hope
you'll tune in for that one too as for
this if you've seen this episode I'm
assuming you've seen the entirety of
series eight what was your feeling on
this series the first series for Peter
Capaldi as the doctor whatever you
thought is that the best is that the
worst does it fall in the middle more
towards the top more towards the bottom
where did it land for you for me upper
half certainly exactly where it lands
I'm I still gotta sort a few things out
in my head but this was good stuff and
it was a good launch for Capaldi but
whatever you think is the case drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it until next time this
council is adjourned